Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Captain John.
Look,
the car star,
Trek's famous next generation captain who for a Frenchman sounds suspiciously
very English.
I made catchphrase is like make it so and tea.
Earl grey hot are profound pieces of advice brought to us from the situations
that he and the crew face throughout their journey and the lessons taught in
Star Trek.
Even though the character and setting our fictional,
the philosophy and meaning is applicable to the real world.
So in this video we're going to explore the meaning behind 10 of his quotations
that we may be able to apply to our own lives.
So let's get to it.
Number 10 things are only impossible until they're not.
Star Trek is a show where faith has been put into the existence of a future,
a future built off social,
political,
economic,
technological,
and other achievements that most people today think are impossible.
Granted,
Star Trek doesn't always explain how these things were achieved and if they do,
it's not uncommon for it to be nonsense techno babble.
But it holds true in the real world as well that what we have today would have
been thought impossible by many people in the past.
Picard knows this and we may remember that not as much as impossible as we might
think.
Number nine being first at any cost is not always a point.
Even in the 24th century.
Some people are still obsessed with personal glory.
Granted,
recognition for once achievements is not a bad thing necessarily,
and competition in science can further progress.
However,
the galaxy,
much like our modern world,
is a very fragile place when being first costs you,
your values,
your dignity,
your health,
even the lives of yourself and other people,
you have to ask yourself,
is it really worth it?
The card does a number of great things,
but not to the risk of his crew or the downfall of his moral character.
Number Eight,
history has proven again and again that will never,
mankind interferes with a less developed civilization no matter how well
intentioned that interference may be,
the results are invariably disastrous.
The prime directive is rule number one in dealing with aliens and the galaxy
basically don't talk to them until they meet a certain set of technological and
scientific criteria.
If we encounter a less developed civilization,
suddenly introducing them to star ships,
phasers transporters,
et Cetera,
could rock the foundation of their society and the perspective of the universe,
which could cause a societal breakdown.
The stories of the prime directive and star trek reveal that we should treat the
spread of technology on our planet and perhaps indeed relations with extra
terrestrials in the future very cautiously.
Number seven,
there is a way out of every box,
a solution to every puzzle.
It's just a matter of finding it.
Star Trek is a problem solving show.
To be fair,
sometimes it's just some random solution from again a sudden Eureka moment
explained through fake techno babble,
but the point is not always the technicalities of solving 24th century problems,
but the fact that the card and his crew often find themselves in situations that
seem impossible.
They're lives are at stake.
Their minds and bodies undergo great stress.
They may be on the verge of losing all hope.
We may wonder how we would react in such situations and to see them push their
way through as an inspiration to us to push our way through our problems.
Number six,
villains who twirl their mustaches are easy to spot.
Those who clothed themselves in good deeds are well camouflaged.
The road to hell is often paved with good intentions.
Think of some of the worst people in history and perhaps some of the worst
people you know personally.
Very rarely do they admit to being malicious and coming out and saying,
I shall envelop the world and evil.
Most of the time they may claim to have good intentions.
They may even have good intentions.
They may be very defensive and find ways to justify the things that they do that
some people buy into,
but they are still doing important things and that is the charming,
well intentioned deceptive criminals that we should prepare ourselves to
encounter in our lives.
Less.
We play a role in what they do.
Number five,
the road from legitimate suspicion to rampant paranoia is very much shorter than
we think.
We may often in our lives,
catch on to a plot or conspiracy going on around us.
Not necessarily just on a macro political scale,
but in our personal social lives as well.
We have to be careful to not jump to conclusions and let our suspicions get out
of control.
History is filled with examples where the existence of a few traders,
for example,
let the crackdowns on entire populations and deaths of innocent people.
Furthermore,
we can find that even when our suspicions have been proven to be wrong,
the paranoia has still built up to a point where it could,
for example,
ruin a relationship between two people,
which must be guarded against number four.
There are times,
sir,
when men of good conscience cannot blindly follow orders,
you acknowledge their sentience,
but ignore the personal liberties and freedom.
Order a man to turn his child over the state,
not while I'm as captain,
even the United Federation of planets which presides over a peaceful earth and a
United portion of the galaxies still has its fair share of blind bureaucrats and
self interested figures.
This quote refers to the Federation ordering data to submit his daughter,
which was essentially another and joy that he had constructed and Picard
response to it.
History is filled with worse examples of people committing catastrophes with the
excuse of just following orders and the cardinal leaves that men of good
conscience as he put it,
have an obligation to refuse orders which are morally outrageous.
You might be reprimanded,
but if a few other people in history have been willing to just be reprimanded,
history might not have been so dark.
Number three,
it is possible to commit no mistakes and still lose.
That is not a weakness.
That is life.
Sometimes in life you may try your hardest,
you may follow a plan exactly.
Everything else may be going perfectly,
but you still do not succeed.
In the end.
It may not be your fault,
although you should definitely be sure of that before you absolve yourself of
blame.
And we may have to accept that this is just a part life.
How we respond to failure regardless of whether or not it is our fault,
is crucial to how our lives turn out.
Number two,
very deep within you,
beneath all the years of pain and anger,
there is something that has never been nurtured.
The potential to make yourself a better man,
and that is what it is to be human,
to make yourself more than you are.
The card here is essentially steadying his idea of the meaning of 24th century
life.
To improve yourself,
to maximize his strengths and conquer your weaknesses in order to live as
incredible of a life as you desire,
whatever kind of life that may be,
the potential to make yourself a better person is something which paccar
believes should be introduced to everyone.
And if more people held that mentality,
the world could be a place populated by better people.
Number one,
someone once told me that time was a Predator that stocked us all our lives,
but I rather believe that time is a companion who goes with us on the journey.
It reminds us to cherish every moment because they'll never come again.
What we leave behind is not as important as how we've lived after all.
Number one,
we're only mortal.
This is more on the route of Picard's philosophy and a meaning he gives to his
life.
This very moment will never come again.
Even if we have a long and healthy life.
This exact time period in our lives will never come again.
It only exists in the now.
The car believes that we should make the most of our lives living as if there is
no tomorrow isn't exactly the best quote for comparison,
but living with the realization that your time on this earth is limited,
is empowering to people like the card.
Captain Picard,
of course has many other words of wisdom and Star Trek in general explores many
other aspects of philosophy in life that are very relevant to our lives even
though they're placed in a 24th century.
I explore some more star trek philosophy in my video,
the philosophy of Spock,
but to really understand all the things that star Trek covers,
nothing beats watching the show itself except for,
you know,
discovery.
Don't really worry about that.
But anyway,
for more videos like this,
in videos on many other subjects,
you should have checked out,
fire learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.